the unexpected consequences of the coup
and Gabon
workers from all sectors are on strike
the demonstrations are broadcast live on
state television something unimaginable
under long time leader Ali Bongo where
descent was met with repression
protesters denounce long working hours
shoddy contracts even sexual harassment
in the workplace we are at our wits end
we come to work stressed every morning
we are insulted there's a lack of
respect and complete contempt towards
workers we are badly treated poorly paid
we have no health insurance
we want a respectable salary even
minimum wage isn't respected things need
to change
deposed president Bongo is free
but his close relatives are under arrest
accused of high treason The Bongo family
amassed a fortune plundering state
coffers in the oil Ridge Nation for more
than half a century
French courts have seized the family's
home in Paris Prime real estate in one
of the city's wealthiest neighborhoods
some French MPS have suggested turning
the 100 million dollar Mansions into
low-income housing but the people of
Gabon want the stolen money returned
outside the ebill's pension fund offices
are long queues some have been waiting
not months but years for State grounds
sometimes there's no water at home and
you have to go and borrow water from
someone else there's no electricity you
have to borrow it we need money to buy
electricity and water and to send our
children to school
the interim prime minister has announced
National consultations but has fallen
short of giving a date for a return to
democracy
everyone has something to say men women
old people young people people in
housing Estates people in towns people
in villages everyone has an opinion and
that's normal so starting next week I'm
going to put out a call for
contributions
contribution
corruption was once the elephant in the
room in Gabon no one dared to talk about
it now it's out in the open for many
people hear the coup is an act of
Liberation Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera